this capsule we will see some
latest variations of the algorithm to
stars as well as other apps
then one of the problems that we can
sometimes meet with the star it's
that our open list and claude can
become particularly successful and so
have little by little we can meet at this
moment there space problems
memory so a very simple approach to
solve this problem there is to
to be inspired by bing algorithms
search you will do but a limit
on the actor who can take open
is closed
and if we try to insert in at the price
of the clause but that would bring us
to exceed the limit but what we do
what we do we only look at
the best elements according to our
evaluation function then we do not insert
to suffer his bed we throw them so if we
makes his father the guarantees of the stars
internal optimality but it can
sometimes worked well and that's often
a fairly fast correction of simple
to do the canvas home guide for
that they can work in a
context where we have problems of
memory
a variant maybe a little bit
better to the extent that we may have
best guarantees of optimality
this is called hydractive says
ping so in what if actually this
what we do is we will put a
limit on the depth of paths
we're going to explore so we'll stop
to explore paths that are of a
depth greater than a certain
value during its star launch
up to the depth limit that has
been specified and then if we do not find
solution in europe no solution
with this depth the limit on
increases by incriminating a little the
maximum depth and we start again
reversing so forth until
we find a solution
so that can prevent
stars to unnecessarily explore
paths that would be too deep for
get a solution
a variant a bit more advanced than I
only go to mention then I you
invite to go to the book of
Nordic springs if you want
to have more details is their curriculum
drop fairsearch or just a mother
band him hester so these are some
variants that use less memory
and can be longer so we
compensates memory usage by a
little more computing time
however, these are variants that will
keep the warranties of the stars and who
will be able to be executed on us from
constraints on the memory that one of
which is accessible and finally I
will mention it faster to cure it
one of the stars which is a variant of
the dynamic star that is to say where the
costs of the arts is lightly loaded during
execution
so I invite you to consult the
literature and perhaps doing a
search on google for example for
go see the information on this
alternation you're interested no we're going
look at some applications so we
focused a lot on the problem
to find two paths find a
way between two cities one could
come back to the problem of the imposing
specifically sorry the problem of is
not so fast so in what
if a state what would that be topless in
our graph it would be a configuration
legal game we have the eight figures and
an initial net empty space of the
initial configuration we want
provide the agent for the challenge or
the riddle is in question
and finally the and ultimately of this
would be a winning configuration by
example where we ordered one two three
up to eight by taking a ride in the
clockwise of curry and in this case
transitions would be all
possible actions from a state
given so in this case we could
move the empty space upwards
would be associated with the north action of which
body and if we called transition
for this draw here is one of the leaders who
would be generated that would be this
configuration of the game then from
this one
they are called transition one of the walls
which would be generated knows what the
nine previous agree and so our
transition function would simply
implement that generation of
states another problem that has been
mentioned in the previous capsules
and that of planning so we have
a robot that we want to see
perform certain tasks to move
some goods in a warehouse
for example in this case also each
transitions actually could
match one of the executions that
can accomplish another robot so
the example here it would be more of a robot
would pass from the work of the room r5
to the room
r i believe in this case we ar 5 6 1
so that generated this stole so our
transition function does for all
possible actions of the robot us
would give out an eye that
would correspond to all
configurations of the environment and
the agent possible and in that if the
no 1 goal would correspond to the
configuration of the robot and
final goods being reached
and so we are in a cock the sic of
geographic search we could
run to star on this type of
problem another application in
the automobile industry is the
manipulation of a mechanical arm where
wants to run a certain
movement by one or more arms
mechanical so that they pass
from a point to a point b without entering
in contact with some objects so
because if we should reformulate a
serious such as possible transitions
among others
would not lead to collisions and
star could allow us to get
a trajectory that would be the most
possible to move from point a to
a point b without coming into contact with
objects to another domain
similar applications would have
in video games have wished
automatically resuscitate characters
to move from one configuration
given to a final configuration
again respecting some
physical constraints in our
resuscitation so and one and the them
contacts or certain transgression
physical
so there are two problems there that come
to finally see it's problems
where we have to calculate a trajectory
geometric properties of a solid avoiding
collisions with obstacles that are
static therefore are little formulate them and
the networks of al baida stars for
attack these problems there it takes
sincerely define a serious one that is going
take too much into account geometry
say of a robot or an object that must
to move and obstacles that must
to be able to fill the kinetics of the
robot what is the degrees of freedom
for the movements of the robot in question
or the animated avatar and provide
in more initial configurations and
final
and we could pass that an algorithm
in star that would give us in
so insee begins continuous
configuration that accomplish is
finally there since one trajectory
valid that would respect our constraints
which will avoid among others the collisions
with objects however both
problems we just saw that of
the cancellation of a video game and
movement of a mechanical arm this is in
does problems that are
basically continues its share that the
position of the arm or avatar in a
scene finally it's much better
modeled from a continuous point of view
with positions ex yt to
of essentially and an approach that
can take for when even used in
star is actually discrete teese is
the problem
that is to say we will take the whole
variables in our state that are
then we will assign them
done we will compel them to take a
number finished not there so if we had a
variable that can take value between
are between 0 and 10
but what we could not do is
rather discreet teaser the value the
parameter in question to the imposing who
take only as value either
0.12 0.1 or 0.2 and institutes of agreement
so once we discussed this
way there our problem but then we can
build a search graph that
is who and discreet is called to star
now I weigh it in the details
on how can we do
it's discretization there and according to
problems it will vary
what is the best way to
discredit another example of a problem
my willing to discredit the space or
the description of the environment of
our agent is the one where we would have a
robot that would move in one in a
given environment where we had
different rooms with doors and
institute since we wanted to do
hurt the leg to complete their skin
to accomplish certain tasks between
other in what if an aspect of
the state of the environment
would like us to be very discreet
tease and that would be the xy position of
robot in the environment
when we prefer to discredit
space and just compounds
the whole environment in boxes
a certain size of a size
restricted and in this case also in fact
the robot would move from one square to
the other so the state of the agent would be
characterized by which box is this
that the robot is holed up and assume that
in fact each is not only the
box occupied by the robot but also
his orientation s that is moving towards
east towards west towards
south in this case we would have
transitions that could be turned
to the left turned to the right or
go straight and in this case
when we go straight ben it
that the robot would change boxes and in
this case the nodes that would be connected
it would be two adjacent squares
according to the direction where according
the orientation of the robot and would
connected together by the action was going
straight ahead